hello freak [ __ ] did you see what the
hell I watched a doctor's response to
what the hell I watched this because I
heard it was like some crazy vegan
propaganda it's not based on science at
all okay they're trying to tell you that
a fad causes diabetes and that is
clogged up and doctors that have looked
at it there's been a ton of debunkers
online attaboy they said this is
pseudoscience is not real like
definitely a vegan diet can be helping
definitely taking a lot of vegetables
can be really good for you and
definitely it's good to have
nutrient-rich foods right whether it's
fresh vegetables or whatever you want to
eat and you could absolutely if you if
you're careful and you're smart about
your saturated fats and unsaturated fats
and you know especially essential fatty
acids and feeling like that
you can live a very healthy life as a
vegan and just do it right but these
guys lie no no they went a little
overboard they didn't know that you
don't take that document what it is is a
vegan proselytising like doc you it's
like you what you're trying to do is get
people to sign up for veganism but
you're in the [ __ ] out of lies and
you're saying things like saturated fats
and all these these things clogged up in
your arteries and that causes diabetes
that's not true like in it in us what
the health what the same guys that made
cowspiracy yeah exactly yeah and they
were wrong about that too when they came
in here they were talking about how many
acres it takes for a cow to graze and
all the negative aspects
there's absolutely negative aspects when
it comes to animal agriculture and I
think it's super important to be honest
about those aspects even when
criticizing it you can't exaggerate it
to make a case look better because the
actual facts are disturbing enough okay
like especially factory farming when it
comes to like cows and [ __ ] and and and
pigs it's disturbing to see them all
stacked up in there like that or ever
being to see those rivers of [ __ ] where
where people run these pig farms but and
they're the [ __ ] comes I'm a filmed it
with a drone one of these giant
commercial places in life [ __ ]
disturbing right and that is straight up
that's enough that's enough there's a
ton of ass
facts that are disturbing and as soon as
you you have these doctors that are just
[ __ ] artists that are saying all
these things that aren't supported by
science and when this one doctor goes
over all the different things in what
the health that are incorrect you kind
understand what it is they mean well I'm
sure they mean well yeah they're trying
to get people to quit eating processed
meat which is a very good idea processed
foods [ __ ] terrible claim whether
it's food with a lot of preservatives
meats with a lot of preservatives all
that stuff is definitely a hundred
percent not good for you
but that doesn't mean that grass-fed
beef is bad for you because it's not
right it doesn't mean that you can't
have a healthy diet with salmon and fish
you know like different kinds of ocean
fish scallops and use that as your
primary protein source and then
vegetables and have like a super healthy
diet because you will you will have a
super healthy diet and you know there's
a lot of arguments to avoid dairy I
think a lot of it depends on the
individual lot of good arguments right a
lot of really good argument really good
arguments in terms of your immune system
inflammation there's a lot of really
good arguments to avoid processed sugar
there's a lot of really good arguments
but I think it's like we're talking
about earlier when you were talking
about if you found those those girls
Kroll's in Qumran you would kind of like
wow this is what it is and I get all the
[ __ ] all right you know you need to
figure out a way to lean it towards you
will the people are clearly on Team
vegan which is great and it's fine way
to be on Team vegan and do it right is
be healthy be nice and be honestly on
earth yeah there's good to know yeah and
you're going to get plenty of those
there's a lot of those out there no no I
don't want to discredit them and there's
a lot of there's a lot of crazy vegans
too that are just going to get at you
and they just decided now that they're
vegan to just attack everyone who's not
vegan I've seen those two but not just
humans right that's just that's as
humans human [ __ ] so I mean I know a ton
of people that are very happy being
vegan and you're one of them all right
you know and I [ __ ] with you all the
time about it you're healthy dude you've
always been healthy
you know you but you do it right yeah I
mean I've done it wrong like I've been
unhealthy vegan
[Applause]
[Music]